SKYE WANDERMAN-MILNE: I'm Skye,
for those who don't know me.
I've been working on
Control Flow in TensorFlow
for quite some time, with
the help of [? Sarab ?]
and many other
individuals on the team.
And so my goal with
this talk is to tell you
everything I know about
Control Flow that's important.
Let's get started.
I'm going to start
by going over the lay
of the land with Control
Flow in TensorFlow.
So starting with what I'm
going to call the Base APIs,
tf dot cond and
tf dot while loop.
So these are the
primitives that are
exposed in the public
Python API for users
to access Control Flow.
So you have conditional
execution and loops.
That's it.
So you might be wondering, what
about all the other Control
Flow functions I know and
love, like map or case?
These are all built on those two
base APIs, cond and while loop.
They're sort of
wrappers around it
that add useful functionality.
So diving down
into the stack, how
are these primitives, cond and
while, actually implemented?
How are they represented
in the graph?
So in TensorFlow 1.x, we have
these low-level Control Flow
ops.
You might have heard of them,
Exit, Enter, Nextiteration,
Switch, and Merge.
We'll talk more
about these in a bit.
There's also an
alternate representation.
That's what Control Flow
version 2 is all about.
These are the "functional" ops.
And I put "functional" in
quotes because it's caused
some confusion in the past.
It's not like pure functional.
In the programming sense,
they're still state.
But they're higher
order functions
that take functions as input.
So now, the cond branches will
be represented as functions.
So these sort of do the same
thing as the low-level ops,
but the higher level
functionality is all
wrapped up into a single op.
Moving back up the
stack, you might
be wondering what's going to
happen with TensorFlow 2.0.
If you're using Eager
execution, you just write Python
and you just use
Python Control Flow.
So if statements, or loops,
or list comprehensions,
that kind of thing.
So there's no arrow connecting
it to this graph mode stuff.
But if you use tf dot
function, maybe some people
have heard of Autograph,
which is automatically
included in tf dot
function, and this
attempts to take your eager
style, just Python code,
and convert it into new Python
code that calls the TensorFlow
graph APIs.
So it's going to
try to rewrite all
that Python Control Flow, your
if statements and while loops,
into tf dot cond and
tf dot while loop.
So note that Autograph
is just dealing
at this abstraction layer of
the public TensorFlow API.
It doesn't have to dive
down into the low-level ops
or anything like that.
So that's kind of
where we're at.
We have the 2.0 world where you
just write Python that maybe it
can get converted into our
public Graph APIs, which
in turn are producing these
various operators in the graph.
And one more thing.
Right now, in this
new implementation
of Control Flow,
Control Flow version 2,
we are still converting
the functional ops back
into the low-level ops.
This is basically a
performance optimization.
I hope we don't have
to do it in the future.
That's why it's this
faded-dash arrow.
So this talk, we're gonna
focus on the base API
and how it's implemented.
I think there'll be another
talk about Autographs,
so hopefully they can talk
about Control Flow there.
Maybe there's also talk
about Eager execution
and the high-level APIs
that are not so complicated.
So leave that as an
exercise to the viewer.
OK.
So I'm going to start with
going over Control Flow
v1, the original
low-level representation.
You might be asking, why?
Why do we care at all?
So like I showed
in the diagram, we
do still convert the functional
ops to this representation.
So this is basically how
it's executed today, always.
Furthermore, this is still
what we use in TensorFlow 1.x.
So all 1.x code is
using Control Flow v1.
Still very much alive.
And I hope it provides a
little bit of motivation
for why we wanted to
implement Control Flow using
the functional ops.
So I'm going to start
with these low-level ops.
So up here, Switch and Merge are
used for conditional execution,
this is tf dot cond.
Also in while loops to determine
whether we need to keep
iterating or we're done.
And then Enter, Exit,
and Nextiteration
are just used while loops
to manage the iterations.
So let's dive in.
So Switch and Merge, these
are for conditionals.
Let's just start with Switch.
The idea is you get your
predicate tensor in,
this is a Boolean, that tells
you which conditional branch
you want to take.
And then it has a
single data input, so
[INAUDIBLE] some tensor.
And it's just going to
forward that data input to one
of its two outputs
depending on the predicate.
So in this picture, the
predicate must be false.
And so the data's coming
out of the false output.
Merge basically
does the opposite.
It takes two inputs,
but it only expects data
from one of its inputs.
And then it just
outputs a single output.
So Switch is how you start
your conditional execution,
because it's going to divert
that data into one branch.
And then Merge brings
it back together
into your mainline execution.
It's not conditional anymore.
One implementation detail
I'm going to mention here
is dead tensors.
So you might think
that nothing is
going to come out of the
true output of the Switch,
but it actually does output
a special dead tensor, which
is just like a sentinel value.
Like a little tiny thing.
And dead tensors flow
through the whole untaken
conditional branch.
And eventually, you're
going to get a dead tensor
into this Merge.
It just ignores it and outputs
whatever data tensor it gets.
So dead tensors are needed
for distributed Control
Flow, which I'm actually not
going to cover in this talk.
Because it's kind
of technical and I
haven't found it that important
to know the details of it.
It's covered in Yuan's paper.
But I'm mentioning dead
tensors because they do show up
a lot in the execution.
Like, if you look at
the executor code,
there's all this special
case for dead tensors.
This is what they're about,
it's for conditional execution
so we can do distribution.
SPEAKER 1: And retval
zero doesn't help any.
SKYE WANDERMAN-MILNE: Oh, yeah.
And that famous
error message I want
to put on a t-shirt, retval
zero does not have a value.
That means you're trying
to read a dead tensor,
or it probably
means there's a bug.
OK.
Moving on to the low-level
ops we use for while loops.
These manage
iterations, basically.
The concept you need to know
about in execution is frames.
So you have one
frame per execution.
And this is what
allows the executor
to keep track of
multiple iterations,
and allows a single op to
be run multiple times as you
do multiple iterations.
So a frame defines a name, which
is for the whole while loop.
And then it also has
an iteration number.
So the Enter op, that just
establishes a new frame.
It means we're starting
a new while loop.
So it just forwards its input.
It's like an identity,
except that output is now
in this new frame.
And it has an attribute
that's the frame
name, starts at frame 0.
Exit's the opposite.
It just it's like an
identity, except it strips
the frame from its input.
So output is now not
in that frame anymore.
And these can be stacked.
So if you have a bunch of
Enters on a bunch of frames,
you have a bunch of Exits, it'll
pop them off one at the time.
The Nextiteration's just
the final piece in order
to increment that
iteration count.
This might make more sense
when we put it all together,
so let's do that.
Starting with tf cond again.
Let's just work through this.
So down here, you have the
API call that we're using.
So we start, we
have this predicate.
Note that the predicate isn't
actually part of the cond.
It happens outside here,
but then we feed it
into the Switch operators.
So the Switches and
Merges mark the boundary
of the conditional
execution, remember.
So we'll feed this predicate
and then, the true branch
is an Add.
So we have a Switch
for each input,
for x and z, which is
the external tensors we
use in that branch.
You'll note that they
are only being emitted
from the true side of it.
So if the false branch is taken,
nothing's connected to that.
That comes out of Add, then
similarly on the other side,
we're Squaring y, so we
have a Switch for the y.
This time, it's going to be
emitted from the false branch
into the Square.
And then, we only
have one output
from this cond so we
have a single Merge.
Either the Square or the
Add, only one of those
is going to actually have data,
and that's what will be output.
So note that there is
a Switch for each input
and a Merge for each output,
they don't have to match.
And in this example,
the two branches
are using disjoint tensors.
But say, we did the
Square of x instead of y,
then you would have
an edge from both
the true output and the
false output, depending.
Go to the Add or the Square.
Let's quickly, actually,
go over the while loop
API, just to make
sure we all remember.
So the first argument,
is a function.
That's the predicate function.
The second function is the body
that we're going to execute.
And this is where it's
kind of interesting.
So you have some inputs, these
are called the loop variables,
the input to the while loop.
And then it's going to
output updated versions
of those same loop variables.
So the inputs of the body
match the outputs of the body.
Like, same number-type shape
of tensors because they're
just the updated variables.
SPEAKER 2: Can't the
shape-type [INAUDIBLE]
SKYE WANDERMAN-MILNE: The
shape can change, you're right.
Same number and types.
And then the final, we'd
provide some initial input
to start it off.
So that's the 0,
the final argument.
And then the output
is going to be
whatever the final value
of the loop variables are.
And then the predicate function
takes those same loop variables
as input but just
outputs a Boolean, like,
do we continue execution or not?
So now we'll start
with the inter-node.
This, remember,
establishes the new frame.
We're starting a new while loop.
I guess it's called L for loop.
We go through a Merge now,
kind of reversed from the cond
where you start with the Switch.
Now you start with a Merge.
Because it's choosing is
this the initial value
or is this the new, updated
value from an iteration?
That feeds into the predicate.
Note that the predicate
is inside the while loop
now because it has to
execute multiple times.
The output goes
into the Switch node
to choose whether if
it's false, and we're
going to exit the while
loop with that exit node.
Otherwise, we go into the body,
which is an Add in this case,
take the output of the body,
feed it to the next iteration.
Because we have to bump
that frame count, remember?
And then feed it
back into the Merge,
which will forward it
back again and again,
until we get to the Exit.
So, hopefully, this
kind of makes sense.
You can see there's
a loop in there.
That's the while loop.
SPEAKER 3: For sequential
ones, how does the Merge know
to select the z or [INAUDIBLE]?
Because wouldn't neither of them
be dead tensors at that point?
SKYE WANDERMAN-MILNE: I
don't know the details
of how this is implemented.
But I think because
the frame is different,
z only is in the first frame.
Because each frame
is conceptually
like you made a
copy of the body,
it's going to keep track
of different pending
counts for each node in
the body, or the Merge,
or the Switch.
So I think that's why.
OK.
All right, so that's
all I'm going to go over
with Control Flow v1.
It does have some advantages.
It all, kind of,
falls out of the fact
that these low-level operators
are designed to naturally fit
within the dataflow model,
because data graphs are
dataflow graphs.
So you get nice
features like pruning,
works pretty naturally,
because it's all regular nodes,
sort of, for pruning.
You can have parallel execution
of while loop iterations, which
is actually pretty
cool, I think.
Because once you add
in this frames logic,
it kind of naturally keeps
track of all the pending counts.
It runs just like a regular--
like, if you unrolled
the loop and the data
will flow through
as far as it can.
Ops will be executed
as soon as they can.
It just kind of works.
However, there are
some disadvantages.
It's very complicated.
Like, you can see that
this is a bunch of nodes
to express what in most
programming languages
is like one line, like while.
This shows up
especially in gradients
and nested Control Flow.
You end up with all
these crazy edge
cases where you didn't hook
up the inner Merges correctly
or whatever.
As a result of this complexity,
higher order derivatives
are not implemented.
This is not like a
design problem, per se.
It's just it's so
complicated and there's
so many edge cases no one
has been able to do it,
or has wanted to do it.
Similarly to graph
construction being complicated,
the runtime is complicated.
Because you have to have
all this dead tensor logic,
all this firm logic, and
it's very intricately baked
into the executor.
And this makes it hard
to read and maintain,
and also, adds
performance overhead.
It's hard for other
downstream things
to analyze and make sense of.
An example of this
is [INAUDIBLE]
has been trying to do
[? auto ?] clustering for XLA,
and so he has like
whole docs written
on how to handle dead
tensors, because they
can show up anywhere.
Similarly, XLA actually
represents Control Flow
in a functional way
if in while ops.
So when they consume
TensorFlow graphs,
they have to pattern-match
this crazy stuff back
into just the while op that
originally produced it.
And especially with gradients
and nested Control Flow,
it gets very complicated.
There is a number of edge cases.
This was actually one
of the main motivations
for building Control Flow v2.
Because we were fixing
so many bugs and how
this was represented in so many
edge cases, that it's like,
we just need a simpler
representation.
OK.
So, hopefully, this
will be simpler.
I can fit it on
one slide for both.
[LAUGHTER]
So tf dot cond, it's
just an if op now.
You have the Boolean
predicate coming in.
These arrows represent the
type signature of the op, not
individual tensors per se.
So then this could be
any number and type
of tensors coming into input.
And then similarly, any number
of type tensor is coming out.
They don't have to match.
Then these represent,
they're technically
function attributes,
but they're basically
functions attached to this op
representing the true branch
and the false branch.
So they're like,
little subgraphs.
One thing to note that's
important with these functions
is that the function
signatures have to match.
So the functions have the same
inputs and the same outputs.
The inputs and
outputs don't have
to match, what but they have to
match across the two branches.
SPEAKER 4: [INAUDIBLE]
the type, not values?
SKYE WANDERMAN-MILNE: Yes.
Sorry.
Well, we're just talking
signatures right now.
So just type and possibly
shape in some cases.
Yeah, it doesn't even have
to be implemented this way,
but it is.
It makes somethings
simpler to think about.
But keep that in mind.
Similarly, tf dot while loop
just turns into a while op now.
Now all our inputs and outputs
are just the loop variables.
Because, remember, the predicate
takes those loop variables
as inputs.
So you have a cond function
or a predicate function,
takes a loop verbals as
input, output, or Bool.
And then the body function that
takes the loop variable inputs
and outputs, the updated
version, which will eventually
be-- the final value will be
updated output from the op.
So does this make sense?
This picture.
SPEAKER 4: One thing to clarify
is, in tf cond it doesn't have,
actually, any concept of
variables in the higher level
API.
So this is things we
capture and we take
care of making sure they match.
So from the user's
point of view,
they don't have to
do anything special.
SKYE WANDERMAN-MILNE: Right.
That's, kind of, like the
while op very closely matches
the TensorFlow semantics.
But the if op is a
little bit different.
They have to match [INAUDIBLE]
inputs at all, because we do it
through closures and API.
That's like, you do
it within your code.
So if this is good
for everyone, I'm
going to move on to
going over gradients.
I'm going over how gradients
work in Control Flow v2.
It is somewhat general.
It's much simpler to think
about with the functional ops.
So let's start at a high level.
Just conceptually, what
is the gradient of a cond?
It's basically,
just another cond.
And you take the same
predicate, and you take
the gradient of both sides.
So if we took the
forward true branch,
then we want to take the
gradient of the true branch
on the way back.
Make sense?
Hopefully, this is good.
While loops, a little bit
more complicated, not too bad.
So say we have this
forward while loop,
you have your cond
and body functions.
Just assume it executes end
times for now, we just know.
So now the gradient, we
have to execute the gradient
of the body function N times.
Like we just have
to do the reverse.
Imagine an unrolled loop, we
did N invocations of the body.
Now we're going to
do N invocations
of the gradient of the body.
And you pass in the grad y's
or cotangents or whatever.
And those are your
loop variables.
Then your predicate,
now, is just
this counter to make
sure we execute N times.
So, hopefully, this makes sense.
The big question is, how
do we know what N is?
The answer is that, at
least in Control Flow v2,
we just add a little counter
to every a while loop.
That just outputs the
total number of iterations.
And we don't return
this to the user,
but we can wire it through to
the gradient when we need it.
Does this make sense
at a high level?
We're going to dive
into the details.
But this is concept.
OK.
So I'm about to go into
more concrete examples.
And I'm also going to
discuss the tricky part
about gradients, which
is intermediate values.
Basically, when you
have a data dependency
from the forward pass
to the backwards pass.
So start with cond.
Here is a similar diagram.
I rearranged it to
make it fit nicer.
But one important
thing to notice
is that now the arrows
are actual tensors.
They're not just type
signatures anymore.
So the predicate is a Boolean.
In this example, there's only
one input and one output,
maybe they're different
types, who knows.
Doesn't matter for this example.
And then you have the
true and false functions
with the same types.
OK.
So here's the gradient function.
It's just another if.
This time we're dealing
with the cotangents instead
of the initial forward values.
And we have the gradient
of the true function
and the gradient of
the false function.
Looks good so far.
Hopefully.
If there was no
data dependencies
between the forward and backward
pass, like if you're doing y
equals x plus 1,
this is all you need.
But what if somewhere in
the forward pass, let's
say the true function,
there's an op?
And we need to use its
output in the backwards pass?
So this is conceptually
what we need to do.
We need z in the
gradient function.
This is a problem,
because you can't just
have an edge between two
function definitions.
You need to have
inputs and outputs.
Like, they need to go--
The If ops need to be attached
to each other with an edge.
This doesn't make
sense by itself.
So we're, basically,
going to do just that.
We're going to make
inputs and outputs.
We're going to add
them to the if op.
So let's do that.
So we're going to output
z from true function.
And then similarly,
add it as an output
from the if op, because the if
op is calling true function.
And then we're going to add
it as an input to the gradient
if op.
And add it as an input to
the gradient true function.
OK, there's still
one problem, though.
And that's that now the true
and false branches of both if op
don't match anymore.
We need them to have
the same signature.
So let's just add some
inputs and outputs.
Starting on the gradient
side, this is fine.
We can just add z as an
input to the false function.
It's just going to ignore
it, it's an unused input.
But on the forward
pass, this is a problem.
Because we need to add z as an
output to the false function,
but we don't actually
have anything to output.
It's like, what is
this question mark op?
And it needs to be the same
type, and possibly shape,
if we want to keep a strong
shape, or a fully known shape.
And we might not know
the shape until runtime.
So what we do?
I had to think about
this for a long time
and came up with many
different solutions.
And I partially
implemented all of them
before coming up
with using Optionals.
Optionals are maybe types.
You've heard of that?
It's a special
kind of tensor that
can hold another tensor
inside of it or not.
So it's just a wrapper that may
or may not have another tensor
inside of it.
And it's also a tensor.
It's like a variant tensor.
So the true function is
going to return an Optional
with the z value inside of it.
The false function is
going to return an Optional
with no value inside of it.
OK, great.
Now they're the
same type, Optional.
Could have the same
thing inside them.
In a gradient true
function, we can
unwrap that Optional
to get the raw z value.
And then the false
function still
just ignores it, which
is great, because there's
nothing inside of it.
I didn't know how to draw
this, but that's what we do.
So all the intermediate
values that
are needed by the
grading computation
are added as Optional
outputs of the forward pass.
Does this make
sense to everyone?
That's it for cond gradients.
SPEAKER 3: Conceptually, what's
the difference between doing
this and the dead tensor stuff?
SKYE WANDERMAN-MILNE: Oh.
Yeah.
Great question.
I meant to go over that,
so thank you for asking.
At a high level,
this is just how
it works in Control Flow v1.
The gradient if cond
is another cond.
You can express that
into low-level ops.
But the dead tensors
are the big difference.
So v1 was, kind of, using dead
tensors instead of Optionals.
And you would just
have that edge
because there's no
functions [INAUDIBLE]..
You could just draw
that edge between
the forward and backward pass.
And if it's the
untaken branch, you'll
have a dead tensor
flowing across that edge.
There's none of this
matching business,
you just draw the edge.
SPEAKER 3: The interesting
thing with the Optional
is that it tells you in the type
of it that it might be that.
Where in the dead tensor you
had no such information around.
SKYE WANDERMAN-MILNE: Right.
SPEAKER 3: So someone
like [INAUDIBLE]
doesn't have to spend as much
time reverse engineering.
[INAUDIBLE] exactly what it was
meant to do complicated cases.
So now what tensors
might be dead or not?
SPEAKER 3: So this
is, essentially,
a much more explicit way
of making it clear what it
be done versus what might now.
SKYE WANDERMAN-MILNE: It's
kind of like, more complicated.
Like, this was actually
simpler in Control Flow v2,
because you're just
like, draw the edge,
and the executor will take care
of all this dead tensor stuff.
Yeah, it made the whole system
more complicated as a whole
to support that.
OK, so let's move on
to while gradients.
So again, we're dealing,
now, with concrete tensors.
So input x, output y.
They have the same type but
they are different values.
The body function--
note that I used xi
because it's run multiple times.
And each time it
takes, it might be x
or it might be an
intermediate value
and outputs the updated
value of y of i.
Then I drew the
cond function small.
And I didn't draw as
inputs and outputs,
because they don't really matter
that much for the gradient,
but they're there.
It does have them.
So same thing for the gradient.
Very similar to the
cond case, now we're
dealing with the cotangents.
Hoping this makes sense.
We took the gradient of the
body and we're running N times.
I forgot to draw N,
too, but it's there.
Same scenario.
Oh, no.
What are we going to do?
We can't just draw this edge
between the two function
definitions.
So this time, we don't have to
worry about the matching thing
anymore.
Thank goodness.
We'll add the input
to the grad body
function and the
grad cond function,
but that's fine because
we can ignore inputs.
But we have a new problem,
which is that there's actually
multiple values of z.
Because the body
function is going
to execute multiple times,
there's no guarantee
that this op that
outputs z is going
to output the same value
on every iteration.
So we actually have to
output all the values of z
from the forward
pass, and we don't
know how many that
will be until we run it
and take them as input
to the gradient function.
So we use stacks,
otherwise known
as accumulators in
the code sometimes.
So we're going to
start with an empty--
we use tensor lists, which are
kind of like tensor arrays,
but not stateful.
You can see in these
little function signatures,
we're going to start
with an empty tensor list
that we pass through the while.
And then in the
forward pass, we're
going to push values onto
that stack, or that list.
And since it's stateless,
you take the list
in as input and the value
you want to add to it
and it, conceptually, returns
you a new list that has
that new element added to it.
Under the hood it
doesn't actually
have to make all
these copies, I hope.
Similarly in the backwards.
So then we're going to
keep pushing values,
outputting these new lists,
and keep pushing to them
until we get the full list
with all the values in it.
That's output from
the while loop.
Actually, I have a
picture for this.
So I guess the point is
that, in the backwards
pass you just pop,
opposite of push,
to get the value out again.
And so, this is a
little bit complicated.
But you start with the
empty list as input,
now these lists are
actually loop variables.
So the stateless tensor list
works quite nicely with this,
because the loop
variable is going
to have whatever has accumulated
so far as input to the body
function.
And it adds the
new z and outputs
that as the updated version.
And so the final
list is going to be
the full list, which you pass
into the gradient function.
It's going to do the same
thing, except popping to pass,
to get that raw value of z.
And then finally, the list
should be empty at the end.
And then, since it's
a loop variable,
we end up outputting
an empty list,
but we don't actually
need that output.
That's just how it works.
SPEAKER 2: I have a question.
SKYE WANDERMAN-MILNE: Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: Are you saying
the gradient values always
[INAUDIBLE]?
SKYE WANDERMAN-MILNE: It's only
when you when you need them.
SPEAKER 2: It's just
always [INAUDIBLE]..
OK.
Thank you.
SKYE WANDERMAN-MILNE: Yeah.
That's a good question.
SPEAKER 4: Now you
could [INAUDIBLE]
in the normal TensorFlow
graph probably
is able to remove them.
SKYE WANDERMAN-MILNE:
Yeah, that's
the way it actually used to do.
Although, that's a little
weird through functions so
we changed it.
SPEAKER 3: Another question.
Does this imply that
in your while loop,
your memory consumption
is, basically,
linear in the number of
variations you go through?
SKYE WANDERMAN-MILNE: Yeah, if
you have a gradient like this.
That's some future work.
I would love to see
doing re-materialization,
or check-pointing, I think
it's called in the literature.
But we don't do that.
SPEAKER 2: Can explain
again, in the if, why
can't you draw a line
just from the original--
SKYE WANDERMAN-MILNE: Oh, yeah.
The blue boxes are
function definition.
And then the while op is
going to call that function
many times.
So it's sort of like, if you're
writing two functions in Python
and they're not
nested or anything,
they're just side by side.
You can't take an intermediate
variable from one function
and use it in another one.
It's going to be like, I
don't know what this is.
You have to output
it then have it
as input to the other function.
Or at least in TensorFlow we
don't have closures or anything
fancy like that.
So that's how we do it.
Does that make sense?
SPEAKER 2: Kind of.
SPEAKER 3: The value for
a particular execution
of a function of particular
intermediate value
of a particular
function execution
doesn't have a name that
can be addressed in order--
And if it had a name,
it would greatly
complicate the lifetime issues.
We wouldn't be
able to [INAUDIBLE]
intermediate
[INAUDIBLE] functions.
SKYE WANDERMAN-MILNE:
Or maybe another way
is that these
function definitions
aren't actually in the graph.
I draw them as if they are,
but they're off to the side.
All you see are the while ops.
And then when you call the
function, then you see that.
But you only see
it for that call.
So it's like this z op in
here doesn't exist out here
in the main graph where this
gradient while op can see it,
or in this other
function definition.
Oh, and to compare to
Control Flow v1 again,
same general idea.
These while ops could be the
whole mess of low-level ops
and, due to some true while
loops, represent it that way.
The big difference, this
time, is in the stacks.
They use the old resource
back tensor arrays,
which were stateful.
SPEAKER 4: We actually use the
resource [INAUDIBLE] stack.
SKYE WANDERMAN-MILNE:
Oh, you're right.
You're right.
SPEAKER 4: Separate nests.
SKYE WANDERMAN-MILNE: OK, yeah.
But they were
stateful, is the point.
So they were
actually just inputs.
They weren't outputs.
And you just modify that state.
One big disadvantage of
this was that you couldn't
take higher-order derivatives
because you would exhaust
the stack once,
and it's stateful
and you can't get
it back anymore.
Whereas these, it's
this full list.
Because it's a
stateless thing, I
can pass it to another
while op, no problem.
So coming back to
Control Flow v2.
Let's recap what's
good and bad about it.
So now we can take
higher-order derivatives
because it's very simple.
The gradient code, when
it's looking at an if op,
it doesn't know if
that if op was actually
the first derivative
of some other if op.
They're are all the same.
Inputs and outputs
just are normal.
It's much easier to
convert to the XLA
if and while ops and
downstream TPU integration.
Graph construction
logic, I hope is simpler.
Take a look for yourself.
So besides being
easier to maintain,
this lets us give
better error messages,
and hopefully there'll
be fewer bugs.
OK.
So now assuming that we
just run the functional
ops, even though I said
we don't, assume we do.
The execution could
be much simpler,
because we don't
have dead tensors
or because we use Optionals now.
And we don't have frames because
it's managed by the while op.
But the disadvantage
of running these ops
is that they aren't as
performant for a number
of reasons listed there.
So we could fix this
with the functional ops.
And it would make sense to do
this because a lot of these
also apply to just regular
function calls, which
are kind of a big deal now.
But for now, we decided to
just take the functional op.
So right before you run it--
so you've already constructed
the graph, you're
ready to run it--
we're going to convert it
back into the old low-level
representation.
So now we get rid
of the disadvantages
because we're, hopefully,
just running the same thing.
But we also don't get our
simpler execution because we're
still running the old thing.
So we call this
lowering, because they're
sort of lowering to this
more low-level form.
This was, basically,
a staging trick
so that we can do all the
graph construction stuff, which
is taking quite some time,
without having to worry
about the execution as much.
Because there were
still some issues.
It's very similar to
function in-lining.
An if op and a while op are kind
of very fancy function calls.
And so this is how
you in-line them,
with these low-level
level dataflow operators.
And so it runs with in-lining
before anything else happens,
and this is so we
can take advantage
of any downstream optimization
or placement or whatever.
In the case of
Control Flow, we want
it to work the same as it did
before in Control Flow v1.
And I think Eugene is
fixing this all up,
so this is actually true now.
As of, like, last week.
SPEAKER 5: So this converting
will be removed eventually?
SKYE WANDERMAN-MILNE: I
would love to see it removed.
Oh, yeah.
So right now we
in-line everything,
including function calls,
because similar story
for functions, it makes
a lot of things easier.
I hope that we don't
depend on this forever.
That we sort of
do try to make it
so function calls are just
as performant and as good not
in-line.
Because it's the same
for Control Flow.
If we always assume
everything's in-line,
then we're never going
to be able to get
our simpler execution and
just run the functional ops.
Because they're very, very
similar function calls,
they have the same problems.
So if you fix it
for functions it's
not a huge step to, then,
fix it for Control Flow.
Where are we at with
Control Flow v2?
It's still under development.
There's bugs and features
that need to be implemented.
But it's basically on in tf 2.0,
if you're using pure 2.0 code.
So remember Eager, doing his
own thing, just use Python.
And then, Control Flow v2 is
always on in tf dot functions.
There's no way to
get old Control Flow.
If you want to run new Control
Flow in either 1.x code
or you're using a
compact dot v1 dot graph,
those still use the
old Control Flow,
you can use this environment
variable to turn it on.
So now when people ping
me in and are like,
I have this horrible
Control Flow bug.
I'm like, try the
environment variable.
And sometimes it fixes it.
Or sometimes it at least
gives an easier to debug error
message.
Unfortunately, I
would love to have
realized the glorious future,
where it's all new Control
Flow.
Old Control Flow doesn't exist.
We can delete that code.
I don't know if it makes
sense to do the work
to make it so we can
turn it on in 1.x code
because there's a
few big blockers.
Namely, functions don't
work with ref variables.
And so by extension,
these functional ops
don't work with ref variables.
That would be a lot
of work to implement.
And the question that you asked
about how we add the gradient
outputs when you
request a gradient,
only when they're needed,
which it will only
know after you build
the gradient graph
and see what incoming
edges you have.
This actually breaks sessions.
Sessions do not like it when you
add inputs and outputs to ops.
And will potentially make
your session unusable.
You'll have to
make a new session.
So in 2.0 we don't
have sessions, great.
But in 1.x we definitely
have sessions.
Another little note.
In addition to Control
Flow V2, there's
a new effort to
re-implement tensor arrays.
And I sort of hinted
at this by incorrectly
stating the old tensor array as
stacks but it's the same idea.
Tensor arrays were these
resource back stateful things.
Now we're going to
make tensor arrays.
It's still the same
API, so nothing
should change for the
user, but under the hood,
we're going to use immutable
tensor lists, which are
variants instead of resources.
And so you get
higher-order derivatives,
it's easier to reason
about something
that's dataflow style instead
of stateful in our dataflow
graphs.
It's nicer.
And then in particular, an
area of active development
is that we do need to make these
new tensor arrays work in XLA.
So this is kind of annoying,
because we've kept saying, oh,
the new Control
Flow [INAUDIBLE],,
it's going to make XLA so easy.
It's just going to work.
But we do have to
implement this one thing.
[? Sarab's ?] working on this.
I think it's almost there.
We'll see.
SPEAKER 4: Getting there.
Question.
So is it true that
TensorFlow [INAUDIBLE]
where you only use
the [INAUDIBLE]??
SKYE WANDERMAN-MILNE: Yes.
Yeah, so it's
maybe theoretically
different from Control Flow,
because it's tensor arrays.
But tensor arrays are so
tightly linked to Control Flow.
And we only support
the new tensor arrays
in new Control Flow
because we don't
want to deal with
the stateful thing.
SPEAKER 2: You don't know
what tensor array is.
Usually when you do
Control Flow and it models,
you have something like an
RNN, that computes something
for [INAUDIBLE].
And you often want to
take a single tensor that
represents the results of
all time steps together.
And tensor array is
the data structure
that lets you do that.
SKYE WANDERMAN-MILNE: Yeah.
I don't think there's too
much use for tensor array
outside of while loops,
I'm sure I would stand
corrected if I looked into it.
So these are some details
on what's going on here.
That's all I have.
I'm going to end on
this slide so you can
look at the beautiful picture.
And I guess we have plenty
of time for questions.
So what was your Control
Flow v1 question?
SPEAKER 3: How does it work
with the branches [INAUDIBLE]??
SKYE WANDERMAN-MILNE:
Oh, good question.
So this is when you
have a tf dot cond,
remember just takes lambdas and
captures everything by closure.
So you could just not
close over anything.
Like, return one or two.
SPEAKER 1: Or like, it's a
sourceless op like [INAUDIBLE]..
SKYE WANDERMAN-MILNE: Yeah.
It uses the predicate.
It wires together all the
dataflow using the predicate.
And in particular,
you can also have
a cond that doesn't
return anything,
it just has side effects.
And I think in
Control Flow v1, it
will return to predicate value.
I thinl it does that
in Control Flow v2
because I wanted to test
the pass in both cases.
But it's a little arbitrary.
SPEAKER 4: So the
way to do this is
you have ops that have a control
dependency on something that
depends on the Switch.
Because [INAUDIBLE] propagates
through [INAUDIBLE] as well.
So this is how it's actually
implemented in Control Flow v1.
SKYE WANDERMAN-MILNE: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Well, it can't
depend on the Switch.
It has to depend
on like one output.
SPEAKER 4: Yeah.
So you have a Switch
of the predicate.
And on each side
of that [INAUDIBLE]
that takes the predicate twice.
Then you have an identity
op on each branch.
And every op that's inside
one of the Switch branches
has a control dependency on
that corresponding identity.
So because, then, this
propagates through control
edges, it makes things work.
SPEAKER 1: That makes sense.
SKYE WANDERMAN-MILNE: That's a
part of why we were able to do
[INAUDIBLE].
There's a lot of storage.
Yeah?
SPEAKER 2: So when you
described the graph modification
for taking gradients of if, when
does this modification happen?
Does it happen when
you construct the if op
or when you're taking gradients?
SKYE WANDERMAN-MILNE:
Great question.
It happens when you
take the gradient.
SPEAKER 2: The gradient.
So for those--
SPEAKER 3: Does that depend
on whether you're using tape
gradients or tf dot gradients?
SKYE WANDERMAN-MILNE: No.
SPEAKER 2: We could
[INAUDIBLE] early
if you're doing tape gradients.
We currently do not.
SKYE WANDERMAN-MILNE: Yeah.
SPEAKER 4: So that means for
those function arguments,
or functional attributes, you
cannot draw lines between two,
but you can modify one.
SKYE WANDERMAN-MILNE:
Yeah, you can
modify them to add
inputs and outputs, which
you're not really supposed
to do with sessions.
But we do it.
The reason we do it when you
request a gradient is that, a,
if you never take
the gradient we
don't want to add extra stuff,
although it could get pruned.
SPEAKER 4: You want
to look [INAUDIBLE]..
SKYE WANDERMAN-MILNE: It makes
your graph look nice at least,
to not have all
the extra outputs.
And also, you don't
know which intermediates
you're going to need until
you build the gradient graph.
So if we did it
with the tape, we
could say, oh,
presumably because you're
running with a
tape, you are going
to want to take the
gradient at some point.
SPEAKER 4: We can
actually ask the tape
if the tape is
going to integrate
into one of those outputs.
We can't answer their questions.
SKYE WANDERMAN-MILNE: So
then we could proactively
create the gradient
at the same time
as you create the forward pass
and add the outputs there,
all at once.
But since we have
the two code pass,
we just do it the same
in a two code pass.
Because with tf
doc gradients, you
have no idea if
you're gonna call it
or not until it happens.
That's a good question.
Functions work the same
way too, because they
have like a similar--
if you just have
a function call,
you'll have the same
thing with intermediates
and you'll have to add
inputs and outputs.
So we're back in
Control Flow v1, right?
This is what it looks
like, this stuff.
What if you want to run your
branch functions or your body
or whatever on multiple devices?
So I don't totally
understand this myself.
It's going to be brief.
Cond, it's pretty simple.
You just do it like
normal, I guess.
You add the sends and
receives, dead tensors
can flow through these.
So this is why you
need the dead tensors.
Because for the untaken
branch, you basically
need to tell other
device, this isn't taken.
Stop waiting for inputs on this.
So you can shut
down or whatever.
SPEAKER 4: Another,
we could have chosen
to send the predicate instead.
But was a simple modification
of the existing TensorFlow
that had a huge cost.
If I had chosen to
send the predicate,
we wouldn't need so much of
that tensor propagation and all
the bugs associated with it.
SKYE WANDERMAN-MILNE: Dead
tensors are kind of crazy.
In really big graphs, you will
spend time just propagating
all the dead tensors, and
send data across the network,
or whatever.
It's one of those things.
We added all this
stuff and now this
is very conceptually simple.
You just add the
send and receive.
It just works.
Can we do the same
thing for while loops?
Just add the sends and receives.
This time it's going
to be in a loop.
Seems fine.
It's not fine.
The problem is that
this device doesn't
know that this op is supposed
to be run multiple times.
I guess we didn't forward
the frame information.
SPEAKER 3: It doesn't know
how many times it should run.
SKYE WANDERMAN-MILNE:
Well, it's going
to run once or like 0
times, then you'll have--
or maybe the dead
tensor will work.
But if you run it
once, it's just
going to immediately shut down
because it thinks that it has
to run once, like a regular op.
So the solution, you, basically,
build a tiny little while
loop on the other device.
And so you can see
there's no real data going
through this computation.
But it's just used through
carefully placed control
dependencies to drive this
op as many times as you need.
So this is like a whole
little while loop built just
to run this op n times.
This while loop is indirectly
driven by the real one.
SPEAKER 3: It's driven
by the predicate.
SKYE WANDERMAN-MILNE: Yeah.
Right, exactly.
You can see that this guy
does not have a predicate.
SPEAKER 4: So we're essentially
sending the predicate around
for the while loop case but
not doing it for the cond case.
SKYE WANDERMAN-MILNE: And we
build a little tiny while loop
to actually use that predicate.
SPEAKER 4: And essentially, if
we wanted to partition into two
ops, we would have
to build something
like this for both the
cond and [INAUDIBLE]..
Or it would at least
look simpler, I think.
SPEAKER 1: Well, the control
could be centralized.
SPEAKER 4: Well, you
could send the predicate
to other places, yes.
SPEAKER 1: [INAUDIBLE]
execution, yeah.
SKYE WANDERMAN-MILNE: Yeah.
SPEAKER 4: You would need a
while loop [INAUDIBLE] device,
but the predicate computation
only needs to happen once.
SKYE WANDERMAN-MILNE: Do we?
Because we have
multi-device functions,
you could just call that
multiple times, right?
SPEAKER 4: Yeah.
I mean, sure.
SKYE WANDERMAN-MILNE: You won't
get like parallel iterations
and everything.
So that's distribution.
SPEAKER 6: I'm glad
you speak clear.
SPEAKER 3: How did the
intermediate value sharing work
with distribution [INAUDIBLE]?
SPEAKER 1: It
works the same way,
except there's a
lot more arrows.
[LAUGHTER]
Conceptually, they do not
interfere with [INAUDIBLE]..
But you end up with the diagram
to show both at the same time
would be overwhelming.
SKYE WANDERMAN-MILNE: Yeah,
that's a good point, though.
I feel like it's not
immediately obvious
that it works with all
the dead tensors and stuff
between the forward
and backwards pass.
Because now you're like
mixing [INAUDIBLE]..
But it does somehow work.
SPEAKER 4: You need to
think of the intermediates
as happening before you
do the partitioning,
and then you can see
what should happen.
SKYE WANDERMAN-MILNE: I'll
go back to my pretty picture.
Well, thanks, everyone.
SPEAKER 6: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]